le 15 janvier dernier la france entière
était sous le choc après la diffusion
d'image d'une extrême violence de
l'agression de youri 15 ans sur
l'esplanade de beaugrenelle à paris la
diffusion de cette vidéo extrêmement
choquant
youri a été roué de coups par un groupe
d'une dizaine de jeunes
il est depuis hospitalisé dans le coma
un passage à tabac d'autant plus
insupportable qu'il s'est déroulé à 10
contre 1 en pleine journée sur la vidéo
peut observer les nombreux coups portés
au jeune homme notamment au niveau du
visage dans un état de détresse totale
sa mère natalia était venu nous donner
des nouvelles de son fils alors qu'il
subissait de nombreuses opérations à
tâter la tarte parto parto envoyait
l'écran ouvert depuis les événements
lloris se remet doucement de ses
blessures il a accepté pour la toute
première fois de nous livrer son
témoignage sur ce qui s'est réellement
passé ce triste jour de janvier
[Musique]
alors nourri acceptez donc de nous
parler youri alors je vous dis les
conditions de l'interview
youri voulez que j'aille chez lui voilà
il y avait ils étaient stressés de venir
sur un plateau notamment direct voilà
ils voulaient donc j'allais chez lui
j'ai fait donc l'interview chez lui
voilà on a vous allez voir je suis dans
son salon youri a accepté de répondre à
toutes les questions
sachez le et youri aujourd'hui a repris
l'école c'était son premier jour d'école
il était très très très ému d'avoir
alors c'est un garçon de 15 ans et c'est
vrai que youri on l'a senti je les ai
sentis extrêmement marqué par ce qui
s'était passé forcément extrêmement
traumatisés vous allez voir la première
partie donc de cette interview c'est
parti c'est la dernière partie de touche
pas à mon poste
alors dans un premier temps du ori
revenue sur cette terrible agression
dont il a été victime la violence
l'angoissent la peur de mourir les
conséquences il s'est vraiment livrées
regardez moi ça les nourrit
bonjour je suis très content que tu
m'invites chez doit alors ça a été entre
à la maison tu es
oui c'est moi je suis rentré depuis
vendredi soir
aujourd'hui comment tu te sens tu es
enfant tu es en forme physiquement on a
affiné pour maintenant ça va moins ça va
mieux tu as envie de reprendre une vie
normale
un videur autant à la doublette avant on
se rappelle tous des de ces images
effroyables tard vu les images
qu'est ce que ça t'a fait quand tu les
as vus je comprenais pas t'as pas
compris ce qui est arrivé alors
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur ce qui
s'est passé c'était le stelle quinze
jours y est tu te rappelles de ce qui
s'est passé ou pas du tout oui je
rappelle j'étais sur la tlpe o'connell
avec et là on voit dizaine de personnes
et puis après je me suis retrouvé au sol
après il ya la figure comme on l'a vu
mais d'après tu te souviens plus de rien
si ensuite j'étais en plus angoissés du
coup je me rappelais plus trop de coups
et insulté les passants et puis il est
popping mener ensuite puis après je me
suis endormi alors tu es c'est un
déferlement de coûts on l'a vu un geste
a pensé à ce moment là ce que tu te dire
moi je vais je vais peut-être te perdre
la vie si je pense que l'on sent sans
penser jeu je me sentais la peur de la
mort quand même parce que ce qui m'est
arrivé c'est pas rien quand même
puis sans toi il ne suffi t pas tout
allait bien le crâne ouvert dont tu
plaintes sont partout moi j'ai senti que
j'avais du sang sur les mains sur la
tête
c'est donc je me sentais que c'était pas
une bonne situation aujourd'hui au
niveau physique a encore des séquelles
de cette agression
jamais encore là pas mal enfin je vois
clac encore eu au niveau de la tête et
encore si on suppose nc 4 ici au niveau
de l'oeil ça va mieux présentation ça se
retournera parce que tu es passé tout
proche de perdre la vue mais ça je
n'étais pas content je savais pas c'est
bon tu te sens tu es en danger avant de
subir cette cet accompagnement souvent
d'autre talent puisqu'elle parle de
rejet tard vu les agresseurs ou pas du
tout faits les a vus mais je connaissais
même pas il va avoir certainement un
avant un procès il va tu appréhendes ce
moment où tu vas lire voir ou pas du
tout non pas du tout
tu auras envie de leur dire quoi il ya
plein de gens marchent que je te pose
toutes les questions mais il ya plein de
gens aussi qui ont dit que tu faisais
partie d'une bande que c'était suite
voilà que c'était des représailles
qu'est-ce que tu réponds à ça alors vous
allez voir la réponse de youri là-dessus
ouvrages et c'est déjà la première
partie de cette interview
beaucoup d'émotion il est traumatisé et
ça correspond à la violence de ce qui
s'est passé alors juste pour revenir sur
l' enquête
elle a été très vite onze personnes
mises en examen
6 incarcéré la plupart sont mineurs et
domicilié à vanves dans les
hauts-de-seine et certaines sont
poursuivis pour tentative d'assassinât
et participation à une association de
malfaiteurs et donc on attend la réponse
de youri lenquette elle s'oriente vers
un règlement de comptes entre bandes aux
autres groupes
alors justement des revenus par là sur
tout ce qui entoure cette agression
l'enquète les agresseurs les accusations
les rumeurs regarde y'a plein de gens
marchent que je te pose toutes les
questions mais il ya plein de gens aussi
qui ont dit que tu faisais partie d'une
bande que c'était suite voilà que
c'était des représailles
qu'est-ce que tu réponds à ça c'est vrai
tu sais pas je veux pas partir de son
pendant qu'un conte amis comme tu peux
aussi des travaux photo x tu as vu tout
ce qui s'est passé autour de toi tu es
le soutien de de plein de gens
ap griezmann tout le monde a été choqué
par par ces images
qu'est ce que ça t'a fait de voir tous
sa tête ait eu conscience que tu étais
devenu un symbole ou pas oui ça m'a fait
plaisir en achetant à remercier tourner
toute situation qui m'ont envoyé dans le
moindre euro
la lettre ou même les infirmières et les
aides-soignantes et cetera tout cela est
tellement souple ça me va c'est pour ça
que quand tu vois tout ce déferlement
médiatique autour de toi qu'est ce que
ça te fais ce que tu dis j'ai envie de
leur dire laissez moi un peu tranquille
et laissez moi vivre ma vie et oublier
tout ça ou est ce que tu as envie de
leur parler ou ou tandis vraiment classe
ça se calme et que tu passe à autre
chose comme tu m'as dit non je préfère
ça se calme
bon on arrête un peu avant j'étais pas
une star j'étais personnes enfin j'étais
juste un collégien j'étais heureux je
suis content là aussi la chose encore
ouais donc j'étais juste un côlon géant
avant et là ça sent la faire passer à
d'autres personnes qui consultent des
choses que moi mais j'ai pas envie
d'être une venir et stage est pour une
impression quand tu vois toute cette
violence qui s'est abattue sur toi tu
vois qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
problèmes entre gare entre banques
qu'est ce que tu as envie de leur dire
quand tu vois toi à côté de quoi tu es
passé la chance d'avoir du soutien et
tout mais c'est personnel du fonds ne
sont pas façon de soutien et j'aimerais
leur donner ma force clôture a cédé ce
moment-là difficile c'est pas c'est pas
une seule photo c est ce que t'as pas
envie de faire passer un message comme
quoi voilà aujourd'hui il faut mieux
avoir d'autres priorités et que c'est
vrai comme tu dis c'est pas c'est pas la
bonne solution
c'est pas ça qu'il faudrait faire un
tour à faire on a un avenir à construire
mais c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire en ce
moment là surtout la sq on se complique
un moment pour tout le monde la trouve
ça bon ben moi je trouve qu'il faudrait
pas continuer à me battre comme ça ce
n'est pas la solution
tu vas reprendre l'école
dans quelques heures quelques minutes tu
as envie de retourner à l'école doit
revoir des amis de reprendre l'école de
envie toute cette histoire soit derrière
toi on n'en parle plus que ça soit fini
ok je retourne comme avant au collège 30
pour moi alors comment ça va se passer
parce que tu vas même passé par une
entrée spéciale ce qu'il ya plein de
gens qui t'attendent devons pas eu tous
proviseur kita qui a vu avec des parents
comment ça allait se passer
donc prenons un principal qu'il a parlé
à calcutta corner enfin de voir un peu
pour être pour voir mon retour et c est
ce que ça va te faire changer tout ce
qui s'est passé ou pas du tout si ça va
me faire changer avait déjà fait changer
je pense dans quel sens au total 30
prendre conscience pour moi tu as vu que
tu prends conscience des vrais priorités
de la ville at on a froid tu as quel âge
aujourd'hui oui 15 ans bon bah et
maintenant tu as plus qu'à vivre tes
rêves et à oublier toute cette histoire
en fait ma mère si oui ça me fait très
plaisir de t'avoir vu j'espère que tu
vas pouvoir rejouer au foot bientôt
voilà que fait des gros bisous mais de
loin voilà à youri oui je trouve qu'il
s'exprime très bien déjà poindre à gazon
et de 15 ans il est extrêmement
courageux d'avoir répondu à cette
interview parce qu'ils répondent à
toutes les questions
et puis quoi qu'il arrive qui est des
histoires de bande ou pas personne ne
mérite d'être tabassé comme ça donc on
lui souhaite de retrouver une vie
normale le plus rapidement possible et
malgré toi l'égide l'a très bien dit
voilà il s'agit de savoir si oui ou non
il ya une expédition punitive
parce que lui voilà il dit qu'il ya pas
vraiment demande mais il ya vraiment des
bandes
il ya une bande à beaugrenelle qui
s'appelle la rd4 il ya une bande avant
qui s'appelle a2b s
effectivement on a suivi les gens sur
xenapp et tout ça j'en ai caméras de
surveillance est effectivement voilà moi
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on lui demande
pourquoi il avait un tournevis quand
même dans la poche même si sa maman dit
que c'était pour un cours d'arts
plastiques exact on voit la mairie va
vous ferez des interviews comme une
sorte d'aveu quelque part quand il avait
voulu demander les résolutions dit oui
je vais essayer d'être plus calme et là
ça veut dire qu'avant elle n'était pas
calme et que donc ça laisse entendre pas
mal de schubert si on verra merci en
tout cas à ses parents nous avoir permis
de
verret cette interview
m